did you know that 87 of data science
projects
never make it into production that's
just one
out of every 10 ai projects
so how do you make sure your project
does not become
one of those 87 percent i am priyanka
vergara and in this video
i will walk you through steps to
operationalize your machine learning
workflow
using vertex pipelines so your project
becomes one of those
10 successful ai projects we will look
at mlab's framework
and vertex ai pipelines which helps you
break down the complex multi-step ml
workflow into a pipeline
and ensure that each step runs in a
reproducible auditable cost effective
and a scalable way
in contrast with typical software
systems which are traditionally code
centric
ml systems involve an intricate
relationship between
data code and the models
now data and models are unique artifacts
with their own dependencies and pitfalls
and the joint management of these three
artifacts is a challenge in delivering
and maintaining production machine
learning systems
that is what ml ops is
ml ops is a culture in practice that
aims to unify
ml system development and operations
and guide through the challenges of
taking ml projects
from experimentation to production it is
just like devops but
for ml hence mlobs which handles
managing the life cycle of data
models and code let's start with a high
level ml ops framework
so the first step is ml development
which is inherently experimental where
data scientists and model builders
explore and transform the data sets
explore different algorithms train many
models and then compare them
then the second step is continuous
training
now production training should be
automatable and repeatable so
it can take new data or other triggers
and generate
new and better models on demand and then
the third step
is model deployment which is really all
about continuous integration and
continuous delivery
this involves running a b tests
evaluation of model behavior in
production
and then approving them for releasing
following a rigorous auditable
and even reversible ci cd process
and then lastly it's continuous
monitoring you need to continuously
monitor your models when they are
running in production
because you want to get a sense of how
they're performing
this is important to ensure the quality
and business continuity but also crucial
for getting
high quality signals into how to improve
a model
for your next iteration model management
and governance is basically the step
that applies to
all of these steps it's the it's the
entire framework
we need traceability verifiability and
auditability
at each stage of this workflow ml
pipeline models this
ml ops workflow a pipeline is a way of
modeling a workflow
as a set of connected steps each step
takes as
input the output of the previous step
and performs some additional
computations and then produces
outputs that can be utilized by the
future components now here in this ml
ops workflow
to keep the spirit of experimentation in
the ml development
phase we recommend using the reusable
training pipelines and the reason for
usable pipelines is
because the data scientists can share
components amongst themselves so they
don't have to start with a blinking
cursor
and to rerun and iterate quickly to
create those optimal models
the output of this step would be the
trained
pipeline source code which you feed into
the continuous training phase the
pipeline generates
generated earlier can be now treated
like a software application
and is version controlled and deployed
through ci cd process
as a training pipeline that can now be
invoked with new data or parameters in
production as needed
now the output of this step would be
your trained
model and then the output of the model
deployment
is your live predictions and these
predictions can
not not just be predictions but also
logs
and other records of production
inferences
now the output of continuous monitoring
because you are monitoring
um the train the model continuously the
output of this continuous monitoring
is those alerts that go out to the team
so that they can continuously uh measure
and monitor what the model's performance
is looking like
is it degrading or triggering rollbacks
and retaining
a b testing of any candidate models
the model management and governance
capabilities obviously as i said earlier
span
across the entire framework including
the features such as
model registry model approvals and model
provenance
now what are vertex pipelines vertex
pipelines help you automate
and monitor your ml systems by
orchestrating
this ml ops workflow in a serverless
manner
they are based on containers which
help you make the ml ops process
uh really portable and scalable and the
vertex pipeline store the
workflow artifacts using vertex aiml
metadata which makes it easier to
analyze the lineage of our
workflow and the items that are being
created
for example an ml model's lineage may
include
training data the hyper parameters and
the code that we use to
create the models which are critical
pieces of information to
understand the changes in performance or
accuracy of
our ml systems now as you can imagine
managing this metadata
by yourself in an ad hoc manner can be
difficult
and time consuming and vertex pipelines
makes it easy to do that now vertex
pipelines
support both kubeflow pipelines
and also tensorflow extended
now if you are already using tensorflow
tensorflow extended is a good choice for
you
it provides a rich set of components
that helps you
take the tensorflow code and make it
into an ml pipeline
i did a video on tfx not too long ago
which i will include in the description
below
now if you're not using tensorflow then
use
a kfp which is an open source machine
learning pipeline
it offers a great deal of flexibility
it's easy to plug in
code from any ml framework including the
ml frameworks that aren't python based
such as apache mxnet
now you might ask why do i need vertex
pipelines
if i use kubeflow pipelines already
today now the biggest
reason is that it is managed
and because it is managed you don't have
to
maintain or create servers by yourself
now when you're using kfp you need to
build scale and maintain a kubernetes
cluster
all by yourself but with managed
pipelines
we don't have to do any of that work
it's all serverless
okay so in this video we got a quick
overview of ml ops workflow
and vertex pipelines what's next let's
take a look at vertex pipeline's demo
in our next video in the meantime try
out the codelab linked below
and subscribe to get notified about the
next video
you